when people in neighboring France will
have to wait at least another week
they're currently locked down until May
the 11th after which is going to be
compulsory for people to wear masks in
public Paris correspondent Charlotte
Kaminski next then looks at the shifting
attitudes to keeping covered from next
week everyone in France who uses public
transport that includes taxis and the
likes of uber will be obliged to wear
one of these now if you work in a job
where you can't physically distance
yourself from your colleagues if you
work in a supermarket or in a school or
attend a secondary school you'll also
have to cover up and if shops request it
all shoppers will also have to dawn a
facemask to enter the well via vehicle
of yours we're going to have to live
with the virus since no vaccine will be
available in the immediate future since
no treatment has yet proven to be
effective and since we're far from
achieving the much-talked-about herd
immunity the virus will continue to
spread among us 2020 it seems will be
the year of the mask but just a few
weeks ago the advice from the French
government was very different
we are requisitioning all stocks in
production of medical masks we'll
distribute them to health professionals
and to the French people affected by the
corona virus in fact the French
government even went as far as
requisitioning all the masks in France
meaning that they were only available by
prescription or for health workers while
anyone found with one of these and was
looking to potentially sell them felt
the full force of the law and when some
French mayors in France tried to enforce
wearing masks as compulsory they were
taken to court the interior minister at
the time said that orders to wear masks
were a thorny issue so what prompted
this huge u-turn well some French media
outlets have reported this was simply an
issue with supply and demand France
didn't have enough masks so they were
not necessary but production has since
been ramped up and the tune has now
changed we must wear them as the
sciences change too and anyone who
doesn't will face fine to add insult to
injury health workers are furious that
masks will suddenly be available for all
when they've often had to go without how
can it be that our caregivers could not
be equipped with masks when the
staggering numbers of masks sold to the
public by certain distribution channels
announced with great fanfare all the
while the latest advice from France's
government goes over and above the hwo
zone guidance if you are healthy you
only need to wear a mask if you are
taking care of a person with kovat 19 it
also advocates that masks are only
effective if they are worn and disposed
of properly
now what's perhaps even more bizarre is
that the French government is now
demanding that people cover up after
years of telling them not to such as
france's ban on the full face veil in
public areas now the arguments used to
bring in that law included that face
coverings prevented the clear
identification of a person and they were
social hindrance on an open society well
good luck with up with one of these and
only a year ago France approved a bill
banning protesters from using masks
violators could face six months in
prison and a fine of thousands and
thousands of euros it really seems to
some that the French government is
perhaps making a policy on the hoof and
who knows by this time next week it may
have changed its mind again
and decide that we don't need face masks
after all Charlotte dubitzky
RT Paris
you